CHRIS BANES: Chris Banes.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm Nick Butcher.
Hi.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I'm
Richard Hyndman.
Hi.
CHRIS BANES: We're going to keep
it short this week, as
we're all busy guys, and
we're going to keep it
down to half an hour.
So should we get started
straight into any questions?
Hi, Giuseppe.
GIUSEPPE: Hello.
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: Shall we get
straight into the moderator?
NICK BUTCHER: Let's do it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, we're
going to focus primarily on
the moderator this week because
we're down to 30 minutes.
So anyone who spotted
on Monday--
we put a post on Plus Android
Developers saying we're
bringing it down, making it a
bit more of a compact show,
and be more of a guide to what's
actually been going on
in the show afterwards,
as well.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, and we might
be trying to play with
the format quite
a bit, as well.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
through all of Andrew K.'s
questions unless
we [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
moderator machine saw the post
on Monday [INAUDIBLE]
and put like 28 questions in.
CHRIS BANES: OK.
Let's go for it.
So [? Everland ?] has asked,
"will all developers be able
to reply to comments
on Google Play.
If so, is there an
estimated date?"
RICHARD HYNDMAN: That is
one of the things we
usually put in the--
NICK BUTCHER: Top of the show.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: --top
of the show.
We won't be announcing any
roadmaps, things that aren't
[INAUDIBLE] talk about,
blah, blah, blah.
NICK BUTCHER: But we have
[INAUDIBLE] said that the idea
is to get the reply to reviews
out to everyone.
We're just taking some time
building the features, and
things to support that.
So it's kind of in a small
testing group at the moment.
Not that small.
OK.
Next question.
Shall we go from the top?
"Is there an API to
programmatically build a video
frame by frame?
I want to do this to be able to
screen capture from my app
so I can convert what is
happening on the screen into a
video and upload it to YouTube
from within the app." And
that's asked by Neo
in New York City.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No, there's
not an official
Android API for that.
I guess you could do it.
You could grab FFmpeg or
something and put one together.
You could have a look at using
the media code at classes to
try and put one together.
But it certainly wouldn't create
a video stream with an
output you could upload
to YouTube.
NICK BUTCHER: It's not
automated that way.
You'd have to do some kind of
color space conversions and
all this stuff, turn it into
a stream, basically,
from the bit map.
It will be extremely
[? non-trivial. ?]
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, the main
trouble you're going to have
is getting the actual screen
shots and the actual--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
It's OK.
CHRIS BANES: True.
But it's going to be
slow [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, it's
not going to ideal.
So no, not really,
there's no--
NICK BUTCHER: So an alternative
to this, though.
I've seen a bunch of games,
especially, who want to do
this kind of thing, want to
capture footage and upload it
to YouTube.
And what they found easier
is to almost
capture the input events--
like what the user's pressed and
time codes and whatnot--
and upload that, which is quite
efficient, to a server.
And then almost, like, replay
the action and generate a
video on the server.
And from your server, upload
it to YouTube.
So that's a possible
alternative.
I don't know from your
description whether that would
work for you, but it's something
to consider.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah,
that's a good point.
Trying to video a 25, 30
frames-a-second game as it's
playing could probably have
quite an impact on
performance, as well, writing
that app to the memory and
then converting it and uploading
it afterwards.
OK.
Welcome to Johann, as well,
and Paul [? as well. ?]
Hey guys, thanks
for joining us.
JOHANN: Yeah.
PAUL: Hi, guys.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL: Hi, I put one question
on last minute.
[INAUDIBLE] very lastminute.com
today.
Sorry about that.
I'm just wondering about if you
guys have come across any
browsers that do two-way SSL
using the key chain.
Have you heard of anything
like that?
NICK BUTCHER: Nope.
CHRIS BANES: Nope.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I assume you
mean Android, at least?
PAUL: Yeah, sorry.
Android.
On the Android.
Yeah, on the Android device.
Anything on the Play Store
anyone know of?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No.
I just had a quick search
of the Play Store.
There aren't that many high-end
browsers [INAUDIBLE]
try them out.
But no, I've certainly not
tested that many of hte brands
[INAUDIBLE]
we'll see in a future
list anywhere.
PAUL: All right.
Cheers.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: All right.
Next muffin.
Matt's not here.
He should get our next muffin.
NICK BUTCHER: Matt's sick today,
so we might have to
bench Google TV questions
until next week.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: He's
probably watching.
NICK BUTCHER: Get
well soon, Matt.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Come
on, next one.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, so I'll
read the next one, then.
Next question says, "what is
the current status of app
encryption in Jelly Bean?
Blogs reported in August that
it was disabled, but
conflicting reports from
users and devs--
if [INAUDIBLE]
SDK 16, as in Android 4.1, and
[? paid up ?] is published
this month, will it be encrypted
on all devices?"
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I think
yes is the answer.
Last I heard, it did go live
and then there were some
issues, so we kind of pulled it
back out, played with it,
fix them, put it
back in again.
But that was all resolved
months and
months and months ago.
As far as I know, the app
encryption has been working on
Jelly Bean for many
months now.
CHRIS BANES: Here's
a question--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: For paid
applications from the Play
Store qualify.
CHRIS BANES: Here's a question
from [? Weiful. ?]
It's a design type question.
So, "is it fine to have a
horizontally scrolling views
[? locker view ?] pager in
a [? verti-scrolling ?]
scroll view?" Apparently he's
seen many apps that do this.
And, "does this go against the
Android design principles?"
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I think he's
talking about the kind of BBC
News style app, [INAUDIBLE]
style app, where you have a
list of horizontally
scrolling views.
And it's quite a good way of
laying out information on an
Android device because you can
flick through it both ways
with one hand.
So if you have topic-based
information, it could work.
But from a design
point of view?
Do you want to?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
No troubles with that.
I guess be careful that it
is easy to navigate.
You don't want the user to feel
lost at any point, so
make sure you've enough highway
signs, or whatever you
want to call it, that the user
knows exactly where they are.
And also be careful of your
finger tracking, as well,
making sure you're locking
in one direction.
It can get quite annoying if
you're trying to scroll down
and you have a slight movement
one way and it cancels it or
it starts scrolling
another way.
So just make sure that all
that works well for you.
But yeah, from a design point
of view, I don't see any
problem with it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
I guess it gives you
the ability to have
infinity times something.
[INAUDIBLE] amount of data.
So instead of just having one
infinite scrolling list, you
could have an infinite number
of infinite scrolling lists.
Infinity times infinity.
So much more data.
NICK BUTCHER: Let's go on.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Next one.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
So, [? Nani ?]
in California asks, "After the
end of any key event, root
view [? import ?]
calls focus search on
the view, which
currently has focus.
In the case of list view, there
is no view at the top
and bottom.
The root view will return
a different view.
How does ListView handle
this scenario?"
CHRIS BANES: Have a look
at the ListView source.
Handling focus is tricky,
it's quite complex.
So it's all in there, so it's
[INAUDIBLE] doing it, really.
I don't know the intricacies of
it, because it's different
for each implementation.
So ListView will do it linearly
as it goes down,
whereas GridView will do left,
right, in a grid view.
So just have a look at
the source and see.
NICK BUTCHER: Tricky.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: But
one of those great
things about Android.
We can always just [INAUDIBLE]
it off by
saying look at the source.
CHRIS BANES: It's
pretty readable.
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: So, next
question from
Andrew K., in Sydney.
"When passing parameters to
an intent, do you have any
thoughts on why some methods
use ArrayList--
e.g., putStringArrayListExtra.
I always thought it was
bad practice to use an
implementation instead
of an interface.
Why not put StringListExtra.
CHRIS BANES: I had a look at
the source [INAUDIBLE] this
morning and I couldn't see a
reason why they've done this.
I guess it's just previously
there was a performance
penalty with using interfaces.
AL SUTTON: It might also be that
when you define the AIDL,
you have to define concrete
types and list isn't a
concrete type.
CHRIS BANES: That's true.
Yeah, that's probably
it, actually.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Nice.
Good to have you back, Al.
AL SUTTON: It's a pleasure.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OUYA.
OK?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, that's
pretty much the answer
[? to it. ?]
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
Next one, yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Should
I go again?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: So one's just
popped up on moderator as I
was looking.
[? Azertas Set ?]
asks, "If I have a progress
dialog showing in a fragment
when I download data, how can
I remove the dialog if the
phone comes back from
soft close?
How can I prevent the dialog
from being leaked?" What's
soft close?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I was going
to say, what do you think a
soft close--
CHRIS BANES: [? Hitting ?]
home button?
AL SUTTON: Does he mean
on pause or on stop?
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE] stop.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't know.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
if the phone comes back from a
soft close, and then the app
is still in memory, but it's
just being resumed again?
And it's just all that
relaunching [INAUDIBLE]
you'll get it on resume.
You can either choose on
[INAUDIBLE] pause or
[INAUDIBLE] resume.
NICK BUTCHER: Can you reply,
Azertas, if you're still here
following along, with
some clarification
on what you're asking?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I mean, at the
time when it returns from
soft close, you should get some
kind of indication from
the system that your
app has resumed--
probably [INAUDIBLE] resume,
depending on what you mean by
soft close.
By that point, you
should check if
your download is finished.
If it has finished, of course,
just remove the dialog.
If it hasn't finished,
just update it.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE]
might be to, if you do get your
on pause, to dismiss the
dialog itself and perhaps write
a notification if the
download is ongoing.
And then when you're on
resume, you can cancel
[INAUDIBLE] and re-initiate
the dialog.
Might be a nice way.
So you're never actually losing
track--it's always one
or the other.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE]
the leaking section, you'll
never leak a dialog, all that,
because it would bounce
the activity.
So as soon as the activity
goes, your dialog will.
So memory-wise, you'll
never leak it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Nice.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
All right.
Next question.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Flying through
these moderators today.
NICK BUTCHER: So Andrew
K. has put another
question in to the moderator.
CHRIS BANES: Of course he has.
NICK BUTCHER: "Once an intense
service enters the on handle
intent method, is there a way to
cancel the processing from
an activity?"
He's after something like the
cancel method on AsyncTask.
But he'd also accept
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
minus nine.
Death to my intent service.
CHRIS BANES: No, there's not.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: There's
no priority
handling, there's no ordering.
It's just the order in which
it receives them, right?
CHRIS BANES: It's supposed to
be a fire and forget type
service, so you're not supposed
to really care what
happens after you've fired it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Usually there's
somewhere in the link
you can build a [? finish in ?]
or
something like that.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE].
It's in [? Railway Spice, ?]
I think, isn't it?
Don't know if you guys have
ever looked at that.
It's a third-party library
out there for doing
this kind of thing.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Hello, whoever
said that, thanks for your
contribution.
AL SUTTON: It's probably worth
looking at this level of
detail setting up a custom
binder and putting the code in
that, and then just having the
main service loop look for a
setting that you're setting
borrow method in that binder.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
It'll pick it up at some
point and dump out.
I'd agree.
If you know that this is a case
that you're going to be
frequently coming across.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, there's
many ways of doing it.
AL SUTTON: Is intense service
designed for long-running
tasks, though?
Because I tend to only use it
for short-running things, so
it wouldn't really have an
activity that would last long
enough to need killing.
CHRIS BANES: No, exactly.
It's fire and forget, so it's
short-lived tasks that should
just be fired on the--
that you want them [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE].
It should be short-lived
tasks.
I think Andrew is using
it as a rest client.
NICK BUTCHER: He has been
one of the first ones
[INAUDIBLE], actually.
He just seemed to run out
of time and space.
Let's see.
He thought about having a
global flag outside the
service which the service
checks when on
handle intent completes.
If the flag is set, then return
results as normal.
Otherwise, discard the result.
This doesn't free up any
resources, et cetera, but it
just means you don't
have to cancel it.
You don't have to worry
about doing [? UI. ?]
Blah, blah, blah.
You could do that.
Proxy [INAUDIBLE]
back end.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Why doesn't
your implementation inside the
intent service check the flag
every so often, as well?
Because if it knows it's not
going to need the result, it
can just kill itself,
stop processing.
I don't know what's
inside your--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I would
definitely take a look at
[? Railway Spice, ?]
because it's definitely built
to do this kind of thing.
CHRIS BANES: The actual
implementation of intent
service is about, I don't
know, 50 lines of code.
So it's not too complex.
If you want to take it yourself
and then add to it,
it's not particularly
difficult.
So that's probably what
I'd say to do.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Well, we've
got a full set of 10 people
inside the Hangout
with us today.
So even though we are primarily
focusing on the
moderator, because we're in
this reduced 30 minute
format-- which, I think, so far,
has forced us to answer
more questions more concisely,
which was one of the points.
Does anybody who has joined
us in the Hangout have a
question for us?
And thank you for joining
us in advance.
Somebody is typing.
Ally.
It's kind of a chat question.
Anybody else?
No heads nodding at all?
All just here for
the experience?
Al's [INAUDIBLE]
now.
Al's [INAUDIBLE] question.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We've
got one-- no
questions at the moment.
OK.
LEONARDO: Hello.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Oh, hi there.
Who is that?
LEONARDO: It's the one without
a camera, because I
don't have a camera.
Can you hear me?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, we can.
Hi there, Leonardo.
LEONARDO: OK, good.
So I'm developing this Android
application, and as part of my
application I've got a web view
which is used to display
the guide on the application.
The data comes from the local
application, because it's
dynamically generated,
so I can't really
use an external website.
My question is, I randomly--
I don't know how to reproduce
it, it seldom happens--
get white pages.
So the page is there, the links
are there, the links
actually work.
Because if I click on the links,
I see that history of
the web view changes
and stuff.
But it's completely white.
This only happens on Android 4,
not Android 2, I can't test
on 3 because I don't have any
devices with Android 3.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Have you
tried the hardware
acceleration in the web view?
It's the first port of call for
all these kind of issues.
LEONARDO: Sorry, can
you repeat please?
CHRIS BANES: Have you tried
looking at the hardware
acceleration--
LEONARDO: No, I haven't.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: --trying
to [INAUDIBLE].
There was a lot of hardware
acceleration optimizations
that have been going into the
web view through Android
3 and Android 4.
And 4.1 and 4.2.
And it sounds like a classic
lack of redraw on the hardware
acceleration.
LEONARDO: Oh, it makes sense.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: So you could
just try, in your manifest,
turning hardware acceleration
off.
Use hardware acceleration
[INAUDIBLE].
If that works for you, then
maybe have a look at our blog
posts on which functions in a
web view do support hardware
acceleration.
Maybe you can work around it.
I hope that you don't have to
disable hardware acceleration
for the whole web view
for the whole time.
But it's definitely the
first thing to check.
LEONARDO: That's interesting.
That's something I had
no idea about.
Well, thank you.
I'll have a look at it.
Thank you very much.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No problem.
Thank you for the question.
NICK BUTCHER: All righty.
[INAUDIBLE] times.
Shall we ask the moderator?
CHRIS BANES: Let's go for it.
NICK BUTCHER: So Andrew Kelly,
again, asks, "If I publish an
app in the Samsung or Amazon
store, and not in the Google
Play store, do I run the risk
of not being able to use the
newer Google Play services APIs,
e.g., Maps or YouTube
API?"
And he expands, "I think if the
user doesn't have a Google
Play account, they can have
an out-of-date version
of Google Play APIs.
Or can these be updated
on a device without
a Google Play account?
What if they have a Google Play
but have never signed in?
Will the APIs get updated when
you do new releases, e.g.,
Maps?"
RICHARD HYNDMAN: He's sort of
asking the moderator, so I'll
just let you go for it.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
I'll just--
so Google Maps, the API is
distributed through the Google
Play services [INAUDIBLE],
which is
distributed on Google Play.
The YouTube API is distributed
on the YouTube app.
So if those apps aren't updated
to the necessary
levels, then you are never
going to be able
to use those APIs.
And so in short answer to your
question, if they don't have
Google Play on their account,
or they haven't signed in,
don't assume you can
use Google APIs.
AL SUTTON: One of the things
about the Amazon store is it
comes on the Kindle Fire,
which doesn't
have Play at all.
So they just wouldn't
be available.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
So make sure you're checking
your services are available
before you start using them.
You're safe if it's published
in the Play store.
If you published it in the other
ones, just be careful.
There are a bunch of services
that are still available.
You could use, potentially, the
web version of the Maps
API instead of the Android
client version.
There's a YouTube [INAUDIBLE]
API, as well, they could
use [INAUDIBLE].
And then maybe fall back on
that, because the Android
native experience delivered
through the Play store is
going to be better.
But if they're not available,
use the web APIs.
NICK BUTCHER: Next question.
"Is there a way to query if the
user has enabled a pin,
password, or face unlock
for their device?
I have an app that requires the
user to enter a pin, but I
could skip this step if I've
trusted the Android device to
have authenticated
the user first."
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
I was looking at
the source for this.
And in Keyguard--
I think KeyguardManager--
there's a method called
isKeyguardSecure.
That's the only real method
that's exposed to a developer
that you can query.
NICK BUTCHER: And there's
different levels of security.
So, for example, a pin or
password is considered secure,
whereas a face unlock isn't
necessarily considered secure.
And these come down from the
device profile stuff.
So where you can have app
[INAUDIBLE] sync profiles, and
so on, which you can require
the app has to be secure.
Or enforce--
a corporate device, for example,
has a sufficiently
complex password.
There are definitions
of what's secure
and what's not secure.
So that's what we're
referring to.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
Just checking in the Android
Developers thread, as well.
There's some comments
going on.
One cheeky one from Beaver
that I'm just
totally going to ignore.
I don't have an answer to
you for that, Beaver.
But there you go.
So I guess back--
unless anybody in the hangout
has a question.
20 minutes in.
NICK BUTCHER: No, it's
prioritize moderator.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Prioritize
moderator.
There's more?
NICK BUTCHER: There's more.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
been busier?
Next moderator question.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
ContentResolver.requestSync
and onPerformSync on my
abstract SyncAdapter
is completed fine.
But on my device, under Settings
slash Accounts, the
indeterminate progress bar runs
forever, and isSyncActive
returns true.
Also, the wakelock detector
reports [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
I read this one, and I'm
guessing you're referring to
AbstractThreadedSyncAdapter
because I don't think there is
an abstract SyncAdapter.
So there's multiple reasons
why this happens.
The fact that you mention a
wakelock is ringing alarm
bells, as you must have
had that yourself.
And there are samples
available on
developer.android.com, which
go through all this.
So I'd of go through that
and make sure your
code is roughly similar.
See if you're doing anything
weird or funky which may cause
threads to keep running
or anything like that.
So there could be millions of
reasons why this could happen.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We received a
message in the chats, as well,
from Marty.
Hey, Marty.
"Are there any special
permissions required for
reading a file from
the SD card?"
There used to not be any
permissions required for
reading a file from the SD card,
but as of Jelly Bean,
you do need now the real
external storage permission.
NICK BUTCHER: Just
to be clear, it's
optional at the moment.
So we are, at some point,
going to enforce this
permission.
Right now, a user
can [INAUDIBLE]
enable developer settings, go
on and make it a strict
permission.
But right now it's kind
of an advisory one.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: If you
target API [INAUDIBLE]
and you [INAUDIBLE]
storage, you get a [INAUDIBLE]
error.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: You get a
[INAUDIBLE] warning telling
you that you should be
requesting the read external
storage permission.
And as Hugo points out, you
definitely need the right
external storage permission if
you're going to be writing to
the SD Card.
MARTY: Thanks, Guys.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Oh, hi there.
GIUSEPPE: Can I ask
a question?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Hey, Giuseppe.
Go ahead.
GIUSEPPE: I have a fragment
with [INAUDIBLE]
AsyncTask that shows a progress
dialog when the
AsyncTask start.
On rotation, I would like to
know what is the best working
solution to keep on the screen
the progress dialog.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I see.
You're going to lose your
AsyncTask when you rotate.
The easiest way, the way I
would normally do it, is
either not use an AsyncTask,
or go stop the on
configuration change
for rotation
and relay that yourself.
If you just allow the system to
perform its rotation, it's
going to relay out, you're going
to lose your AsyncTask
and your dialog, as well.
GIUSEPPE: So I have
to control the
rotation through the manifest?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Either don't use AsyncTask
for it--
I know that an in-line AsyncTask
is very quick and
easy to throw in--
but you could have a separate
thread and a handler to pass
the messages back,
in which case you
control that yourself.
It's not too many more
lines of code.
Or stop the rotation, the on
configuration change going
through to the rotation.
GIUSEPPE: Now, this just
stop the rotation,
it's not to my case.
I would like just that when I
rotate the phone, the progress
download [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I don't mean
stop the rotation as in force
the application to stay
in one orientation.
I mean when the rotation
happens, an on configuration
change message gets passed
into your application.
Or you can request one
in the manifest.
And at that point, you can
request that the layout is
re-laid out.
GIUSEPPE: And this work
also for fragments?
Or work only on the activity?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, it can
work for fragments, as well.
And if you don't have the system
follow through its own
life cycle for the
rotation, then it
won't kill your AsyncTask.
GIUSEPPE: Thank you very much.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It's the way
that things like the YouTube
application do it when they want
to rotate and keep the
video playing.
GIUSEPPE: OK.
CHRIS BANES: Cool.
There's a couple of questions
that you and Andrew K. have
been having a back and
forth chat with.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I know.
I mean, we know how those
computers gained a
consciousness and started
killing him.
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
So Leonid in Israel asks, "I
want to use a content provider
with a
ContentResolver.bulkInsert.
Does he have some kind of cue?
Or how it works when there
is many inserts?"
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Any comment
on that, Chris?
CHRIS BANES: I can't say I've
looked at the source of that.
And I guess--
NICK BUTCHER: The bulkInsert--
yeah, you basically build a
list of content operations,
right?
And then it will basically
loop over them.
So the key thing to do there
is really make sure you're
yielding at the right
point, right?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
If you're doing database--
if you're going to send it to a
database, make sure you use
transactions because you'll
get a performance increase
[INAUDIBLE] the actual
inserts.
Yeah, that's what I'd say,
really, about that.
AL SUTTON: If there's any
concern about it, it's worth
making a block of code inside
the bulkInsert method or
rather in the insert method
synchronized, and that will
enforce single, threaded, one
job at a time on the inserts.
NICK BUTCHER: But I think
probably there is an advantage
of having one core to bulkInsert
rather than in a
loop, perhaps, calling
insert many times.
Because he's going to be doing
lots of [INAUDIBLE] and stuff.
I'd say build them
up and bulkInsert
them is a good idea.
[? Maureen of Hell ?]
in Germany, apparently, asks,
"Is there possibility to show
an animation by redrawing the
same activity with different
data using a gesture
[INAUDIBLE]?
For example, to zoom out into
a monthly overview, or zoom
into a weekly, would it be
better to create two
activities?
Thanks."
So, drawing the same activity
with two different--
so it sounds like you want to
look at something called the
ActivityOptions [? pass, ?]
which will do that
for you, for the
zooming in case, at least.
You won't get the zooming out.
But say you're wanting to open
from a small thumbnail into an
activity, then yeah.
Look at the recent [INAUDIBLE]
animation, which Rich is
beautifully demonstrating, that
no one can see on there.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Oh, come on.
I can see a big white
blob moving around.
I don't want them
to read the--
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
Hangout video.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: But this is
actually part of the animation
framework now, being
able to do this.
I'll stop doing that.
NICK BUTCHER: But yeah, it's
going to be quite tricky if
you do it yourself, unless
you're going to go into all
the overriding pending
transitions
and stuff like that.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, unless you
[INAUDIBLE], and then do it as
a fragment [INAUDIBLE].
Because the fragment transaction
will give you a
way to [INAUDIBLE]
animations to the actual
transaction.
So [? it will handle ?]
a lot for you.
So that's going to be
a good way to--
NICK BUTCHER: But then you
wouldn't be able to animate
the whole chrome of
the window, right?
You wouldn't be doing the action
bar, it's just going to
be the contents within.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: But yeah, two
things for you to take a look
at there, if it helps.
AL SUTTON: Just found
a sentence on
developer.android.com.
The content providers methods
may be called for multiple
threads and so must
be implemented in
the thread-safe manner.
[? It's popping ?]
back to the last question.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Good.
[? Sheru ?]
in India says, "can we suggest
an app for improving the
signal strength through the
Xperia Mini?" No, we can't.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No?
No, I've not seen any apps for
improving signal strength on a
device yet.
There's probably some for faking
the signal strength,
but not for improving it.
NICK BUTCHER: And also not
really a development question.
OK.
So we've got a couple here which
you've got answered, but
we're going to read them out
for posterity's sake.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Down to
1 and 1/2 minutes.
NICK BUTCHER: "With the Google
Play private channel, how does
this work for apps I want to
release internally in beta,
and apps I want to publish on
Google Play [INAUDIBLE]
everyone?
Can I choose a target audience
for each app?" I would say
that's a no.
CHRIS BANES: So when you publish
apps to your private
channel, they're only accessible
to people in your
organization.
NICK BUTCHER: In your
domain, yep.
CHRIS BANES: So it's up to you
under what channel you
actually publish your apps to.
NICK BUTCHER: So if you want
to publish beta to your
company, then you have to
[? upshoot ?] twice?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: And the last
question for the moderator,
another one from Andrew K.,
says, "From within an app, can
I programmatically work out
which app store it was
downloaded from, or do I need to
separate code base for each
store with different features
compiled, e.g. first building
an app that was sponsored
by Samsung?"
CHRIS BANES: So PackageManager's
got a good
method for this called
getInstallerPackage--
for Package--
[INAUDIBLE]
it's not that--
where you give it--
NICK BUTCHER:
getInstallerPackageName.
CHRIS BANES: OK.
And it will give you the package
name of the installer.
So be that Google Play or
Amazon or wherever.
And [INAUDIBLE]
if you need to install
it manually.
And yeah, that's probably the
best way of doing that.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
Done with the moderator, then?
NICK BUTCHER: One
more popped in.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: All right,
while Nick's [INAUDIBLE]
that--
NICK BUTCHER: It's too late.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Excellent.
If you happen to be in London
tomorrow night, we're going to
be hanging out at the London
Android user group over at
Skills Matter near--
NICK BUTCHER: Near Old Street.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: --Old Street.
Thanks, Nick.
So we'll be discussing stORM.
David Chandler from our team
in the US is coming over to
discuss S-T-O-R-M at the London
Android user group
tomorrow night.
So if you happen to be
around London, please
pop in and say hello.
Or, sign up at
meetup.com/android, first of all.
NICK BUTCHER: So I hope
you enjoyed the
new compressed format.
And as we've said, we're
going to be giving
priority to the moderator.
So it really does encourage you
to get your questions in
earlier, which gives us more
time to give you a better
answer, hopefully.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I think we've
got through as much material
in this half hour as we
usually do in an hour.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: So if you've come
for the chat, I'm sorry.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Put it
in the moderator and
we'll discuss it.
OK, thanks very much,
everyone.
Catch you again next week.
CHRIS BANES: Cheers, guys.
AL SUTTON: Thanks, guys.
GIUSEPPE: Bye.